- I mean It's kind of funny
going from Big Bang Theory
to that, I mean you get to like,
it's a completely different
role playing Harley Quinn.
How's it playing a badass basically?
- It's been like therapy for me
- (laughs)
- Because I spend like two
hours in a booth by myself
screaming and cussing
(audience laughs)
- I want this job.
- [Kaley] It's the best!
- She's literally insane.
The shows hilarious but
I'm not trying to be biased
the scripts and the writing is genius,
but it's a lot of screaming
and just, it's psychotic,
I've never spoken like this before.
- Me neither
(audience laughs)
- No, no, no.
- I frown upon foul language
- Yeah, I'm sure.
There was at one point we got some notes,
it might of been from the
network, I'm not sure,
but it was like, it's
just too many F words.
- Probably the network.
- Like if it had to be, yeah, yeah.
And we got this thing, like
you've got to cut it back,
like it was like one after another,
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I mean it was so fun.
- It's a great verb sometimes.
- [Kaley] See it almost comes out
- Its a great verb.
- I love that word.
- I'm into it.
- I know.
- My mom hates that it.
- By the way, so does mine.
- [Kelly] Gosh
- Still to this day my parent,
if I'll say a word, it's like,
(audience laughs)
they can't stand when I cuss!
- My mother, same thing
with my music career
and then I get to this and she's like
"You're having a talk show?
"Okay, you've got to close your mouth"
(audience laughing)
"you've gotta stop."
- Don't talk on your talk show!
- Do not embarrass me with your foul mouth
- [Kaley] That is hilarious.
- Like she is so southern, Mom, I'm sorry.
- You didn't get the
beauty queen perfect girl
but I'm real fun.
- Yes you did.
The most fun!